i'm dustin poirier fighting is just
something i do right right
and and i know that now yeah yeah i'm a
bad [ __ ] though i know that too
that's [ __ ] wow bruh imagine waking
up in the morning and being a bad
[ __ ] i could never imagine every
morning
never goes away morning that's [ __ ]
awesome dude when you look back at like
a fight that you if you could
have a another fighter do one over it
could even be one that you won or it
could be one that you didn't
uh do you have any that pop into your
head that you're like oh that one
um one that sticks out for sure is the
conor mcgregor fight
i uh just way too emotional yeah i just
cared too much about everything going on
and read too much about what people
thought and was he a celebrity at that
point really no not really i mean he was
right a lot of people he had a lot of
hype around him but he wasn't the guy he
is now you know right
yeah now it's almost like he's uh yeah
now he's more of a celebrity
than a fighter yeah or not more than but
it's like
equal yeah and it's different it's
different when people become that or i
notice anyway i can stand up like dave
chappelle will come into the comedy club
and he's like a celebrity you know when
he gets on stage and he'll i mean he's a
funny guy
but he's but if bill burr comes in bill
burr is a comedian like bill bird does
his [ __ ] job
he murders every time like chappelle is
a little bit more like oh look at me
where bill burr is like sneaks in does
his [ __ ] work really good
and leaves you know that um for the love
of the craft
yeah yeah yeah do you start to see that
in your in your line of work too like
some guys when it becomes celebrity like
it seems different
yeah people change for sure start making
money uh people start running up to them
for autographs and they start getting
that
you know recognition in public and stuff
people change for sure yeah the ego is
dangerous huh yeah man
do you worry about that no because i'm
in it for the scrap
you know yeah i try to walk away from
that type of stuff you know right if i
think
if i see a bunch of guys wearing ufc
shirts i'll put the hoodie on and
kind of turn you know yeah yeah you just
want to win the belt yeah i just want to
win the belt man
that's all i want i'm just sitting on
your front porch wondering how could i
be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
blown